some day delivery vans won't be rumbling
around town they'll slip down
residential streets as quietly as mice
the battery-powered version of the
bilingual van is the bar lingo electric
said 20 on it to improve their sales
figures in the utility vehicle class it
reminds car testament Oscar out of when
he drove bumper cars as a kid you step
on the gas which isn't really gas and
the car takes off and quickly gets up to
speed as soon as you let off the pedal
the cart slows down again just as
quickly the only difference to the
bumper car that he sees is the sit to
ins cushier suspension so far back and
unlike a bumper car once the BER lingo
is charged it can drive anywhere
anywhere within a range of some 170
kilometers it has no exhaust pipes of
course but it's got plenty of space
depending on the body style the bread
lingo LX leak can carry up to 700
kilograms
Manta says the new European driving
cycle assessment of fuel economy found a
range of 170 kilometers for the Berlin
go but he sees that as unrealistic
particularly because the assessment is
structured in a way that favours
electric vehicles on emissions ratings
in contrast to an internal combustion
engine which puts only about 30 percent
of its energy into propulsion an
electric motor uses 90% of its energy to
drive the car but when the driver needs
heat and winter the unit consumes
additional electric power instead of
making use of the engine heat and that
reduces the car's range in winter
dramatically my doubtless the bilinga
electric was specifically designed to
meet the needs of commercial buyers an
output of 49 kilowatts and a maximum
speed of some 110 kilometers an hour is
more than sufficient for making delivery
rounds in town said when believes the
rated 170 kilometers range is more than
enough for commercial buyers
instead montes points out that the city
owned by lingo electric is reserved for
commercial buyers only the twins Thomas
vit Mon says commercial car buyers focus
much more on their needs and demands on
an electric vehicle the range for
instance they know their area of
operation and they have customers to
serve in a certain area so they'll be
asking exactly how many kilometers range
it has another factor is what use the
commercial operator will put the vehicle
to of course they'll need it for their
business but with private customers they
need a lot more flexibility they might
suddenly decide they want to take a
holiday in Italy that would be tricky in
an electric van but somebody running a
business won't have those needs and
concerns notes photo executor on the big
spin give a habit rhyme with Z now fizzy
decon
the sip - amber lingo electric is made
for its stop-and-go driving for
noiseless emissions free and comfortable
delivery rounds in town after the last
stop for the day the van can be plugged
into an outlet and recharged overnight a
complete charge takes about eight and a
half hours a fast charge to 80% of
battery capacity can be done in half an
hour at lists at almost 26,000 euros
plus a bit over six thousand euros for
the batteries montes says the Burling go
electric could be just the ticket for
business customers if only the price
weren't so steep but Thomas vid Mon is
optimistic about the future he says as
the car maker sit - one knows the
battery pack drives the price up but
otherwise they've got a good handle on
the technological aspect there the
production is streamlined and
cost-effective the battery pack is
currently the weakest point but once
those go into mass production the prices
will start dropping - and the price gap
between electric and gasoline-powered
cars will narrow today though it's still
an issue mine foxy and Montes agrees the
battery prices drop in the coming years
cars like the bilinga electric will be
far more attractive to small business
owners and deliveries around town